hey guys dark [ __ ] he's doing something
Hey he obviously doesn't care that
you're here huh stop
hey guys I'm Ryan right hey man Madison
baby
Madison baby the wonderfully talented
actress from films such as the master
The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
reoccurring role on the Fosters and can
be featured in outlaws and angels with
Chad Michael Murray check it out how do
you talk like that all the time you
sound so epic
I swear from the last video this video
you are coming on way too strong to me
way too strong whoa wait that's a big
jump
let's go cuz I mean there's a big him we
don't work to do you're distracted today
we're gonna check out five then most
mysterious unexplained videos on the
internet by dark five let's do this five
what a name I know it's really positive
channel even starts with like fire okay
Lisa Lam oh this happened downtown LA in
February 2013 21 year old still Lisa
bland was found dead outside
in Los Angeles we live in Los Angeles
your reformist remains date from the
hotel's elevator and for their final
moments
this music is making me really
uncomfortable
how did no one see this
okay cheering right yes it is making me
so uncomfortable okay yeah this happened
and hotel guest was the winning cuz
their water was like great oh dude no
drugs alcohol or assault season hotel
it's a place I wouldn't saw it we should
stay there one I feel fantastic
video of a terrifyingly creepy latex
female and Rose uploaded from an unknown
source okay for two minutes of 30
seconds see a candy creation repeatedly
sings I feel fantastic
hey music is freaking me out man head
Tina also sends a seductive pose after
changing into a black robe and it's
flickable shot zooms in empty
how this unknown technology today could
make you figure out
webdriver torso
YouTube channels upload 325,000 eek
videos to kind of sometimes at a rate of
one every 26 seconds
well
about there's the same format 10 slides
random little rectangles with electronic
tones each one second
aqua dot trippin
this remains a new purchase [ __ ] you put
your oh yeah like I'm gonna upload
shapes yeah I think it was really way
too much - our scene is highly
intelligent okay it's something to yell
yeah it's some dude just [ __ ] or I'm
not against Wisconsin Mac's head live 40
p.m. the night of November 20th over two
years
hijacked by bizarre Broadus
fortieth
that's the Joker
that's so creepy I feel really
uncomfortable right now
microwave signal
see what I can do
surveys on topic kills babies
oh yeah
stay home never leave and just like
watch Netflix all this is on YouTube
Ryan they're all originating on YouTube
goes out
Oh God oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] I should figure
out what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is man do
something I'm not actually gonna do
something I just I just think they
should do something you know this is
like I am I feel so creeped out right
now hi we need to get some sage and just
like burn some sage yeah like watch some
porn totally yeah no no oh damn we had a
moment okay we almost it
we almost said I'm still creeped out
though so I can't really think clearly
the one with ELISA Lam for some reason I
won't freak me out the most because we
live in LA that that's like our backyard
well not just that the woman's panicking
in the elevator and doing weird [ __ ] and
there's no sin the autopsy showed
nothing so I think she was possessed
yeah I could see imposition I got really
creeped out by it and you know
fascination and curiosity kind of takes
over and this hotel is like known
specifically to women like it's a really
bad hotel for women like the night
crawler stayed there while he killed
people and he would dump it all in the
dumpster he was night stalker okay
whatever his name was
night crawler is a Gyllenhaal character
and or um and the character freshman
same same thing I wonder if they have
like a haunted maze or something there
that'd be fun to go to tell you what if
I ever kill you I'm taking you there
okay guys there's some evidence right
there mm-hmm
if someone kills Madison blame it on me
I don't like talking about this I need
to burn some sage
yeah some of these don't really treat me
out like there's some of our really
weird but you know like the one with the
creation artificial lady talking and
stuff like what creeped me out was when
they were suspecting that this is a
serial killer and it's made of human
skin and the burial grout is that's the
burial ground the shot in the yard that
to me is why they're just trying to be
artsy yeah exactly maybe they're just
trying to
SiC in Devon yeah maybe you're reading
too much into this and no one's really
dead or people are really dead in mass
and I are in denial of the truth your
call just a moment of silence for the
people who might be dead or not who
knows these rectangles hey Dad
some rectangle thing it was like someone
was like how's this upload a bunch of
[ __ ] and people will think weird shits
going up the code spirit yeah there's
nothing even that it's just annoying I
wonder what they put as their tags to
get people to look at that yeah they're
probably over there like Caitlyn Jenner
Kardashian yeah I just bet anything Ryan
Wright pornhub yeah things that people
search for pornhub and they're like
searching for pornhub and then they see
all these red rectangles and they were
like conspiracy theory
you know how much Mormon I'm enjoying
the rectangles with the dude who was
able to hijack the radio station or
something like that with his microwave
you're pretty smart
that's smart um I don't think he did
with just a microwave though I mean I'm
sure there was like some microwave type
is a baked potato and hack the local
news yeah I love how he gets this
incredible ability to hack the station
not get caught and he does it for the
stupidest purpose yeah what was he
saying my favorite part was when he like
starts getting lisp ain't bend over
[ __ ] and spanks him with a flyswatter I
as probably kids like buddy who's like
we should do this at the end just to
mess with people I got a really
important question do you like it when I
guy says bend over [ __ ] to you really
not even if you're like really into it
like no matter what you're just not into
it don't call me [ __ ] we would not be
compatible you're making yourself look
really bad right now by the way but the
Satanic stuff with like talking about
the baby being killed and all that [ __ ]
I feel like they said oh no it's just a
hoax so that way they can investigate
this [ __ ] for real because they don't
want to freak everyone out autumn day
see
witch trials no and I know exactly what
those are
yeah you time-traveled you were there
something like that who should you
should talk there's a phone booth I was
in oh wow
do you name William and Theodore we're
there you know that sounds oddly
familiar but I don't know why well they
were just having like one excellent
adventure well anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the Chanel if you knew
through the Chanel you can subscribe to
the real rejects Madison baby the
wonderfully talented actress you can
find her on her social networks at
Madison Beatty Facebook Instagram
Twitter what do you say and you know you
can follow him to Facebook page your
Twitter person which you obviously are
and vine and periscope
alright guys the shout outs are not
loading so I'm just gonna shout out
someone from the comment boxes right now
shadow requests on the fly in provides
moments well they're all improvised
tomorrow Corey she commented on the dear
fat people reaction discussion video um
she liked what sally had to say I'm
shouting her out because even though the
pitcher is that tiny I don't know if you
guys can see it but it's super [ __ ]
tiny it's like the site looks a little
smaller than the size of my nail here
she's pretty hot she looks pretty hot
yeah yeah you're looking good tomorrow
look good tomorrow at least I think you
do
good who knows I mean does she look
legal I think so
I mean it's kind of hard to tell I think
so if you're legal you're hot yeah I'm
if you're if you're legal but if not
then you're a young and adore basically
what'd he say
okay young adorable cuz the way you said
that was a little misleading